ingleses e italianos van por la gloria
en Turquía el Manchester City y el Inter
de Milán se enfrentan en la final de la
UEFA Champions League la sede el
imponente estadio ataturca en la ciudad
turca de Estambul aficionados de ambos
bandos han abarrotado las inmediaciones
del estadio para alentar a sus equipos
en la previa del partido
el fin de inter ruin creo que el inter
para ganar porque solo es un juego solo
son 90 minutos y cuando el inter va a
una final se convierten en fuertes
guerreros bitcoming
tenemos que ganar y conseguir el
triplete John Stones va a notar el gol
de la Victoria creo que podemos hacerlo
va a ser un juego complicado pero creo
que vamos a ganar
La escuadra italiana dirigida por Simone
isagui llega una final de Europa 13 años
después cuando el estratega portugués
Joseph mourinho guió al Inter de Milán a
conseguir su cuarta orejona por otro
lado el conjunto sky blue con bandada
por Joseph Guardiola está en su segunda
final de Champions en 3 años ansiando
poder traer la primera Champions League
a las vitrinas del Manchester City
Time una vez en la vida por eso vine
solo se puede ganar por primera vez una
vez lo entiendes tienes que estar aquí
para ello
Guardiola contra inzagui erling haaland
contra lautaro Martínez Inter de Milán
contra Manchester City la gloria europea
está reservada sólo para uno
[Música]